devant le lycée polyvalent dumont
d'urville à maurepas les élèves de
terminale patiente pour connaître les
résultats du baccalauréat et enfin les
grilles s'ouvrent à 10h les 500 élèves
découvrent le verdict au total plus de
400 lycéens sont admis ce n'était pas le
bon jury je suis contente j'ai des
meilleures passes tressées mais ça va je
suis content placer leurs protégés la
portance et de la voix après les
mentions
c'est mieux mais si on les a battus dans
la foule une dizaine de parents est venu
pour soutenir leurs enfants ils ont eux
aussi eu leur part d'émotion en vacances
et d'avant et puis est parti pour de
nouvelles aventures
une vingtaine d'élèves devront quant à
eux rester une année de plus au lycée
avant de conseils nouvelle aventure on
reprend des années c'est bénéfique c
on va vraiment bien travaillé pour
essayer d'avoir une mention d'autres au
contraire ont une nouvelle chance de se
reprendre ils sont 80 être admis à
l'épreuve du rattrapage vous êtes de
classe j'avais avis enfin vous rapport
qui met le bac mais pour cette prime ne
met pas alors qu'elle quitte à mettre un
petit pont ssf 9 ils choisissent deux
épreuves
donc il ya une stratégie à mettre en
place c'est la raison pour laquelle il
ya des enseignants des différents lycées
qui sont là pour qu'il fasse le bon
choix
le rattrapage sera organisée par
l'établissement sur deux jours lundi et
mardi prochains une dernière étape avant
de pouvoir profiter des vacances
estivales